is there another celebrity out there who
you're just you haven't met them yet but
you're desperate to meet them
Ricky Gervais Ricky Gervais is such a
choice yeah okay very funny guy the cool
guy it's not I like that I do have a
plan of how you might want to meet Ricky
Gervais well my plan at the Golden
Globes because he was hosting I really
pushed it and all of my interviews I was
like I write hope I get to meet you
Ricky and you know it didn't happen and
I you know Instagram stalked him wow I
sound like a really scary I'm a hunter
and I'm stalking yeah Instagram sure
right um so that didn't work so I you
know he has the his famous bath bath I
know about this yeah Ricky loves to take
selfies in the bath ridiculous selfies
this is a example of a regular base and
then he was on the show and I did one
with him where we were kind of naked
together so those are out there and he
he is obsessed with that he does it all
the time and his personal life is take
those photos right so I decided to take
one as well to see if that could could
get his attention to lure him in yes
what's a video did you bring it here you
took
[Applause]
oh I know that Ricky loves cats
yeah so I took another one right and I
snatched this kitten and I just put it
in a batch this kitten is pushing you
away saying I do not agree to this I do
not want to be a loofa Wow I think
that's gonna work I know if he's a
friend of our show he comes by a lot and
he's gonna find those really amusing he
will reach out to you we'll meet Ricky
Gervais are you promising yes I'm a very
powerful person in show business I
promise you you will meet Ricky Gervais
if it doesn't happen in the next year
you know you can blame I will make it
happen okay
personally I will do everything I can no
one's behind me on this at all no one
here thinks I could make that happen
easy yeah he's at my house right now
he's cleaning the pool I believe in you
yeah okay yes and I will stalk and hunt
you until you do it
okay all right I'd like that
you